yeah what 10 weeks left until baby Nixon
comes do you feel ready for baby do you
feel ready I'm so I'm ready for the next
one yeah I'm excited to meet her I'm
excited to see what she looks like and
her personality and if she's got your
eyes and my lips or whatever it is I'm
just excited to hold her she's kicking
like crazy yeah yeah she's so active
she's gonna be like a future amazing
racer yes amazing race and to pick up
brother alums adjusting Kody's brood is
expanding with their first child
together due this spring I'm trying to
enjoy the last ten weeks of it being
like him and I in the house because once
she's born we're gonna have her and
Paisley and all of our future kids
running around until they turn 18 once
you're newlyweds on top of all this we
actually just had our three-month
anniversary yesterday sure I appreciate
every moment babe so yeah how is Paisley
feeling about becoming a big sister she
wanted to it she wanted a brother but I
explained to her the other day that
she's gonna take on a whole new realm of
responsibility so she's no longer the
baby of the family you know now she's
got a take on that big sister role she's
gonna be at least 7 years older than her
closest sibling so she gets to she's
excited about babysitting she was asking
about that she's like looking forward to
that the girl having a sister first
instead of a brother grew on her she's
very supportive of it but she's gonna be
great we'll get her brother though yeah
well you've got plans for a lot of kids
apparently how many do you want and you
complain about quality time like you
need the quality time to make them
no I I mean right away my bargaining
chip was ten kids and then we whittled
it down to four yeah okay Paisley
included so just three no I think oh my
god when you put it that way I don't
know fives a number yeah five five is
impressive but I like to think in the
future when they're all grown up and
they all come home for the holidays I
was great that's gonna be exactly
exactly Jessica always wanted a big
family yes grown-up you know she only
had one sibling so she understands have
you thought about what kind of mom
you're gonna be I just hope oh my gosh I
just hope that I encourage her to be
outspoken and
take charge and a leader but that's
those are the qualities I want her to be
happy and smart and for formulate her
own opinions as opposed to just
following the masses so she's gonna be a
strong yes as the home life already is
the nursery all set up or do we have
we're using the next ten weeks to get
there oh we haven't started on the
nursery but I'm not worried about it
I I promise you it she's been changing
her mind on the nursery because she she
hates pink and she hates like that the
girl colors but now she's for some
reason change right now she wants to pay
and the girl colors okay so we have some
other house renovations that were just
like tying up before we start on the
nursery and then once that happens it's
gonna I have it all up here okay not
worry then he'll make it happen yeah
exactly and I'll watch and if pregnancy
and home renovations aren't enough to
keep just busy this is a great segue
she's also launched her own podcast now
what on podcast one called now what
mostly because I think that's like the
number one question you and I have
always gotten in our relationship right
here's you know I think I've asked you
that once or twice Bryce has been here
since before Big Brother for us right so
we've interviewed with Bryce before
weird
and then after Big Brother and then
after the Amazing Race basically almost
every good point in our life yeah it's
always great to see you actually oh the
highlights we did Big Brother we did
amazing race then we got engaged and
then we bought a house and we moved and
we renovated and we planned a wedding
and we got pregnant and then there was
this moment where we sat down and we
were just kind of like okay now what
[Music]